c'est ici une région où j'ai mes racines
et je me sens bien 1994 alain juppé part
à l'assaut de la mairie de bordeaux
mais à mont de marsan numéro deux du rpr
il veut révolutionner la capitale
d'aquitaine la conviction que dans la
décennie où les 15 ans qui viennent
bordeaux doit et peut reprendre une
place de premier plan parmi les grandes
villes françaises les grandes villes
européennes et c'est un beau défi à
relever un beau défi la ville est
délabrée au point mort
aux municipales de 1995 les bordelais
choisissent alain juppé pour changer
tout ça dès le premier tour avec 50,2
pour cent des voix en presque dix années
sous juppé
la ville s'est métamorphosé le tramway
en 2003 la rénovation des façades du
xviiie siècle
le nouveau quartier de la bastide
davantage de place faite aux vélos alain
juppé a réveillé celle qu'on appelait la
belle endormie mais en 2004 condamné à
un an d'inéligibilité dans la sphère des
emplois fictifs de la mairie de paris
il est obligé de rendre son mandat de
maire de bordeaux alain juppé de retour
en 2006 une fois encore élu au premier
tour
on a mouillé la chemise
un an plus tard il fait reconnaître le
travail de son mandat précédent
bordeaux est classée au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco bordeaux plus
attractif que jamais en 2012 c'est la
ville au marché immobilier le plus
intéressant de france des quartiers
entiers sortent de terre pour loger les
nouveaux arrivants parmi eux beaucoup de
parisiens attirés par la douceur de la
capitale d'aquitaine sa simplicité
l'humanité bordeaux attire des classes
aisées
les prix de l'immobilier flambent et
certains habitants se sentent dépossédés
le phénomène s'accentue depuis 2017 et
le lancement de la ligne à grande
vitesse entre la capitale et bordeaux un
sentiment anti paris se développe pas
plus de bordeaux pour se caler mais de
bordeaux pour ce que certaines classes
moyennes parisienne ou autre ou
projettent c'est à dire la volonté d'y
recréer paris oui un petit bobo landes
dans un endroit autrefois populaire du
en 24 ans alain juppé a transformé
bordeaux mais en a peut-être aussi fait
une ville trop cher
[Musique]